i did not vote for donald trump in 2016.
i
am voting for donald trump in 2020.
there are three reasons
i'm gonna vote for donald trump in 2020
when i didn't four years ago
first i was simply wrong about donald
trump on policy
second i wasn't really wrong about
donald trump on character but whatever
damage he was gonna do
has already been done and it's not gonna
help if i don't vote for him this time
and third
most importantly the democrats have lost
their minds so
first of all donald trump has governed
pretty conservatively i thought he would
not be conservative in his governance
i was just wrong on that donald trump
radically cut regulation he actually saw
reductions in the number of
man-hours dedicated to dealing with
regulation for the first time in a long
time under donald trump
he appointed originalist judges to the
best of his ability we're talking dozens
of them
textualist originalist judges who
actually care about the role of the
judiciary he cut taxes
jogging in the economy raising its
heights not seen in half a century the
lost unemployment rate in half a century
people having their wages rise at the
bottom of the spectrum
he appointed pro-life people to the
executive branch and pursued pro-life
policy
via executive order he dumped out of the
idiotic paris accords
which were useless and counterproductive
he dumped the even more idiotic and evil
iran deal which gave money to the
iranian mullahs
to use for terrorism as john kerry
freely admitted donald trump crushed
isis
he killed all baghdadi he killed kasem
solomonia donald trump is the first
president of my lifetime not to start
any new wars which is a kind of big
thing
he moved the american embassy in israel
to jerusalem he broke the first
meaningful peace deals there
in three decades in the middle east he
cracked down on china in unprecedented
ways he's resisted using the federal
government to control everybody's life
during covet that's a big
thing this is the biggest government
power grab of my lifetime and trump
refused to do it donald trump restored
due process on college campuses because
he actually
cares about due process or at least as
secretary of education does contrary to
popular opinion
donald trump has not actually threatened
the institutions the fact is
that donald trump may have been hemmed
in by his own people whatever the
rationale he has not threatened the
press
he has not threatened the legislature he
has not used the executive branch
in nearly as powerful ways as barack
obama did trump hasn't been as
conservative as i would like on
everything he's spent
way too much money like oodles too much
money i actually care about that stuff
his perspective on trade is a zero-sum
game i think it's wrong-headed
he's still signed into law at the usmca
which is a pretty good trade deal but
these are problems i've had with a
variety of republicans including george
w bush
trump has governed overall in a far more
conservative fashion than w on policy he
is the most conservative president of my
lifetime on policy
of course ronald reagan left office when
i was four years old second
times change when i said i wouldn't vote
for trump in 2016
i was worried about three things one
policy again i was wrong
second i was worried about the soul
sucking of the republican party to
approve bad behavior
people nodding and grinning at bad stuff
trump did a lot of that has happened
and third i was worried about toxicity
down ballot right losing house seats
losing senate seats
blowing out the republican party with
minorities and women and young people a
lot of that has manifested
but here's the thing it's already
manifested and me not voting for trump
in 2020
doesn't stop that from manifesting like
i've been very very clear on my feelings
about donald trump's character
i have serious reservations to say the
least trump
has some good qualities raise a hammer
in search of a nail sometimes
he hits a nail it's super satisfying and
sometimes he hits a baby and it is far
less satisfying
trump hitting the media is often
justified i mean the media
have exposed themselves as just a pure
dumpster fire of leftist garbage
they've treated him as an enemy from the
very first day they've promulgated false
narratives
they've lied about things that he has
said they have taken
the worst interpretation of everything
he could possibly have said that doesn't
mean that trump hasn't been vindictive
or
petty or immoral he does all those
things trump being unable to focus and
willing to jump on any
rake is not just immoral it is very
often stupid and counterproductive i
mean
you know my opinion on this everybody
knows okay deep down in the cockles of
your heart no matter how much you love
trump
everybody knows the trump administration
with trump on teleprompter more often
and less on twitter would be in a
position to win the 2020 election more
easily
everybody also knows that trump's tweets
damage him with people who don't already
love him
all of that is true right but all of it
is not changing there's a group of
people out there who every time trump
tweets something
newly stupid they get newly enraged i
think most americans
basically this is all baked into the
cake at this point i think it's
important
deeply important for conservatives to
criticize trump when he requires it
when trump does something bad we should
say it out loud we shouldn't hide that
and that's why i've been calling balls
and strikes on trump as a president
since the day he was elected
but 2020 is not 2016. everything that is
bad about trump
is already part of the system it's
already part of the new normal for
better or for worse
and me avoiding voting for him in 2020
doesn't change that third
and most importantly the democrats have
lost their minds
they've lost their minds so members of
the mainstream media
so members of our bureaucracy so members
of academia
these people must not be allowed the
mechanisms of power
our most crucial institutions from
corporate america
to the universities they've been
corrupted top to bottom and giving them
power over your lives more power over
your lives
huge mistake the democrats are no longer
the party even of hillary clinton or
barack obama they're the party of bernie
sanders
and they're just wearing around the mask
of joe biden they're the party of
rashida talib and nohan omar joe biden
is a potemkin village of a candidate he
is not a bulwark against radicalism he
is a facade for it everybody knows it
that's why bernie is touting him
as the most progressive presidential
candidate since fdr
there's a reason that noam chomsky is on
board with joe biden
right i mean if you just watch this
stuff it should scare the hell out of
you today's democratic party
is not even the democratic party of
barack obama's circle 2008.
barack obama circa 2008 supported
traditional marriage
barack obama circa 2008 was not openly
in favor of packing the courts or
getting rid of the filibuster
barack obama in 2008 used to speak about
personal responsibility sometimes like
all of this is just gone the democratic
party is now the party of radicalism the
simple mandate for the democrats is this
they now believe in cramming down their
perspective on
everyone they can via any force that
they can control
they believe that you should be forced
by law to violate your religious beliefs
if it conflicts with their social views
they believe that the science says we
have to destroy the free market in the
name of the environment they say that
unborn babies aren't babies that men can
be women and if you disagree with any of
that
you're a bigot and you're a homophobe
and you're a terrible person they
believe that your right to keep and bear
arms should be heavily infringed if not
outright
abolished they believe that due process
comes second to intersectional identity
that we shouldn't judge you as an
individual
we should judge you based on your racial
group they believe that america is
systemically racist rooted in sin and
evil founded in 1619 not in 1776
they believe that every single disparity
in america can be chalked up to racism
and bigotry and america sucking
they believe in racial sexual sexual
orientation quotas
overt discrimination they believe in a
hierarchy of victimhood if you're low on
that hierarchy of victimhood you should
shut up if you're high on the hierarchy
of victimhood you can say whatever the
hell you want you will never be held
accountable they believe that economic
freedom should be curbed in the name of
income equality they care far less about
growth and prosperity
than they do about some bizarre notion
that equality is its own
good they're complicit in a culture war
on anybody who disagrees they seek to
ruin
anybody who stands in their way and they
will activate the media they'll activate
social media they'll activate their
friends in academia to get all of that
done
meanwhile they'll make room for antifa
and black lives matter they will cheer
the rioting and the looting or at least
they'll go along with it and refuse to
condemn it but if you go to church
during a pandemic
you are a danger to society if you go to
grandma's funeral you're super dangerous
but if you are out there rioting and
looning and burning things
that's just a philosophy guys it's not a
movement it's not an organization as joe
biden said
they literally will not even condemn
antifa okay antifa is a terrorist
organization
they will not condemn it they will not
condemn black lives matter
protests that escalate into rioting and
looting
they think that there's no relationship
whatsoever between an ideology that
suggests that america is at root evil
and that every institution in american
life is infected with that evil and the
writing and the looting
on foreign policy the democrats want to
kowtow to iran they want to re-enter the
garbage paris accords they want to make
nice with china they've threatened to
destroy the electoral college pack the
supreme court abolish the filibuster add
states
by simple majority to vote democrat they
say they'll use impeachment as a purely
political tool
in fact they've even said they want a
congressional committee to use the 25th
amendment to get rid of a sitting
president
they seek to centralize all power in the
executive branch and they hope to
overrun the powers of the states they're
aided in all of this by corporations the
mainstream media
and pretty much anybody else they can
get their hands on they've created a
social structure dedicated to
ostracizing anybody who descends on
leftist dogma if you vote for trump
you are evil your friends should stop
talking to you you should stop talking
to your own parents maybe you should be
fired
certainly people should stop treating
you like a human being so here's the
deal
i'm voting for trump you don't have to
love trump's character you don't have to
like his twitter account to vote for him
you don't have to approve of the crazy
or bad things that he says
or the way he often acts but if you care
about the constitution and economic
freedom and the security of the united
states
you really don't have a whole hell of a
lot of choice you should vote for trump
you should certainly vote against joe
biden and a democratic party
that is running completely off the rails
and now threatens the integrity of the
republic
if they are given the levers of power